These guys use brute force they're strong they're
too strong then they might be a part of the big
three what big threat androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no it's not
there are no wizards doctor strange is a
sorcerer a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
our country is vulnerable we need new heros
let's get to work
we're not a team nope
or partners
co-workers
we look damn good
captain america needs my help
i'm with you to the end of the line
we got a situation here where's the fight
can you move your seat up no
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
falcon and winter soldier trailer video there's a
whole bunch of new footage and easter eggs so
we'll break it all down also explain how this
connects with what was happening on Wandavision
and how it syncs up with the other things that
are happening during marvel phase four if you're
brand new to my channel i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes so be sure to subscribe to get
those episode 1 is coming next week but because we
will be talking about Wandavision easter eggs and
connections during this just careful for spoilers
for everything that happened on Wandavision if
you haven't seen those episodes yet but obviously
we get an even bigger doctor strange moment
that it seems like we got on Wandavision even
though there are a lot of easter eggs for doctor
strange especially in the finale of Wandavision.
Wandavision was just meant to be a direct prequel
to doctor strange 2 with the darkhold chaos magic
and scarlet witch whereas the stuff that falcon
and winter soldier is supposed to be setting
up is just a little bit different but amongst
the other big name drops that falcon is giving
during this the thing that they're teasing is the
flag smashers the big villain group that they're
talking about in all their fight scenes he makes
this reference about them being way too strong as
if they're weirdly super strong like they've all
been juicing and in the mcu you know what that
means so also explain what's going on with a new
version of the super soldier serum on the show
and more weapons plus program stuff more new super
soldiers but just starting with the Wandavision
connections first so just charting the timeline
here Wandavision takes place three weeks after
avengers end game and almost everything on that
show from start to finish took place over the span
of a single calendar week even though there were a
couple flashbacks to even earlier in the timeline
there were even a couple moments on the series
where they referenced calendars with actual
dates with that little heart circled around it for
those of you that were wondering about that they
explained the date was supposed to be the day that
vision and scarlet witch were planning on moving
into their new house that vision had bought for
them before the events of avengers infinity war
he bought the house before they were attacked
by thanos before the black order came along
so with vision not been killed in scarlet witch
not been snapped they would have eventually
finished building that house and moved into it in
that five-year time jump between avengers infinity
war and avengers end game the reason why it's
still a foundation on the show when she shows
up is because she didn't get the letter and find
out about the house till after she got flipped
back so five years had gone by vision wasn't
around to settle documents or just take care of
the construction in the contractors the people who
were actually building the house also probably got
snapped as well fun fact though she still owns
that technically as visions next of kin so she
flies off she still owns that piece of dirt she
could always come back and build the house there
but falcon in winter soldier was originally meant
to be the first marvel disney plus series to air
so it also takes place right after avengers
end game like within weeks so everything on
that show is happening around the same time
everything on Wandavision is happening inside
the hex with scarlet witch and agatha harkness and
people were asking this during all the Wandavision
episodes like how come the other avengers who are
still alive don't come to the hex to try and help
scarlet witch per the way that kevin feige marvel
the russos everyone has explained it the avengers
have sort of temporarily disbanded nick fury when
there's a need for it we'll put together a new
avengers team for avengers 5. so everyone's kind
of off doing their own thing right now and mostly
because what happened with scarlet witch and
the hex happened so quickly they also kind of
explained this at the beginning of Wandavision
two when monica rambeau gets sucked into the hex
because when they walk up there when jimmy wu
and her standing there they find out from the
cops that the magic of the hex scarlet witch's
chaos magic basically alters people's memories
so they just forget that westview even exists so
nobody has been calling for help or anything like
that they're just starting to find out about
it because it's just literally happened in the
last day or so and when tyler hayward and sword
rolled in with white vision he actively prevented
the information about what was going on with
the hex from leaking out to the general public
hoping that he'd be able to kill scarlet
witch frame her for stealing vision's body
and then use her chaos magic to activate white
vision is his new sentient weapon then after that
it happened presumably his plan was to release
false information about what really happened in
the hex and just make it seem like she went rogue
and turned into a villain making himself seem like
a hero in the eyes of the government in the public
so by the time most of the other avengers probably
found out about what was going on including nick
fury scarlet witch had already brought the hex
down and taken off with the darkhold it also
kind of seems like in that jump forward when
we see her in the post-credits scene that she's
actively trying to hide herself from other people
finding out what she's doing like she's in the
astral realm studying the dark hold so the doctor
strange doesn't immediately sends his presence
but obviously the really cool name drop the falcon
gives the big three he's talking about androids
aliens and wizards or as bucky corrects him
sorcerers sorcerer is just a wizard without
a hat a wizard is never late frodo baggins
in the context of the falcon and winter soldier
episodes he's mostly talking about who they think
might be behind the flag smashers so when he's
talking about androids it isn't meant to be like
a white vision reference just because they wrote
the falcon and winter soldier episodes before
they finish writing Wandavision even though
it seems like the order's all mixed up now
because of the virus delays androids is meant to
be more of an ultron reference he's like the only
real big android villain that we've had in the
mcu so far there's always others that we might
see in the future like the super adaptoid and then
we have the iron man armor wars series coming next
year so there'll be a lot of that kind of energy
happening in the mcu in the next couple of years
but aliens would be a reference to thanos and his
army mostly even though there are all kinds of
different aliens that have shown up in the marvel
movies falcon and winter soldier don't really
know about the scrolls yet nick fury seems like
he's still keeping them on the dl in present day
they'll get into that during the secret invasion
series next year so i'm assuming by the end of
secret invasion most of the other avengers will
know what's going on with the scrolls if they
don't already the only real evil magic users or
sorcerers is bucky corrects him that they would
know would probably be a loki but loki really
isn't a sorcerer like he doesn't call himself one
so i'm guessing because falcon is making all these
speculations about who's behind the flag smashers
they have not yet figured out what's going on
with the new version of the super soldier serum
that's going around in the weapons plus program
but in that other footage you see the military
official giving that speech about how the world
is vulnerable we need new heroes that's actually
part of the us agent captain america storyline
like this is part of a larger scene where they
roll him out and unveil him to the public like
we need new heroes and here's one right now the
new captain america that's what all this footage
of the celebration on the football field is about
the military rolling out their new captain america
and it's pretty clear that they've juiced him
up with a version of the super soldier serum
we know a little bit more about what's going on
behind the scenes with thunderbolt ross and that
part of the weapons plus program but the bigger
question as falcons dialogue here implies if the
flag smashers have gotten their hands on a version
of the super soldier serum as well where did
they get it from or how are they replicating it
the way they're making it seem the flag smashers
are supposed to be the villain but baron zemo is
also kind of supposed to be the villain but if
you remember the way wandavision played with the
idea of who the villain is like agatha hartness
was kind of the villain of the series but she
wasn't really a straight-up villain she was more
of a loki style villain you do kind of wonder if
they're going to do the same thing with baron zemo
like where they make him seem like the villain but
he's not really the actual main villain the
way they explain the super soldier serum in
the mcu is that when captain america gets his
dose and then later when red skull doses bucky
those are basically the last times that anybody
gets a version of the purest form of the serum red
skull and erskine were the only two people who
knew how to make the real version of the serum
and when they died they basically used up all
the formula on captain america and then red skull
used up the rest of his formula on bucky but after
erskine was killed and then captain america was
put on ice the military wanted more super soldiers
so they did everything they could to try and
replicate the formula but it just wound up being
diminished derivative versions of that original
purist form that's when thunderbolt ross comes
along and creates the weapons plus program so the
whole idea is is they have these derivatives like
you have the version that he winds up giving to
abomination that's a derivative of the original
formula it's not quite as pure or quite as strong
and that's why with each new iteration of the
weapons plus program thunderbolt ross tried
alternate ways of creating super soldiers
best example of that is during incredible
hulk he explains that he was actually tricking
bruce banner with his gamma experiments he was
trying to use gamma to create new super
soldiers but he told banner that it was
for something completely different so the hulk is
kind of a side effect of the weapons plus program
the way they explain weapon x2 is that eventually
what happens with weapons plus is that a group
splinters off from the main weapons plus program
and goes to canada that's how you wind up with a
canadian super soldier aka the wolverine deadpool
is the exact same thing he's also part of another
splinter program from weapon x with people trying
to create their own super soldiers so in addition
to all the chaos that the flag smashers are
causing on the series the real threat is just
the super soldier serum being passed around to all
the different governments of the world that want
their own super soldier programs we'll see how
they play that on the show but the whole other
thing that's going on here is them slowly setting
up thunderbolts in the background in the iron man
armor war series because war machine is coming to
falcon winter soldier we don't know exactly how
many episodes he's going to be in but it's just
all leading up to armor awards for him the same
way that wandavision was meant to be a prequel to
doctor strange 2 but just in terms of the pacing
and the timing of that you have to think about it
the way you're thinking about young avengers in
the background too so obviously billy and tommy
introduced on Wandavision wiccan and speed from
the comics are still little kids long ways away
from being the teenagers that would eventually
join a young avengers team in the mcu probably
going to be a good long while before we actually
see that young avengers project same thing is
probably going to happen with the thunderbolts
like they'll just start cherry picking villains
like baron zemo from different marvel disney
plus series and from the movies anybody that's
not dead is fair game to join the thunderbolts
and all of you been asking if agatha the
hardness is going to come back for sure
100 percent i think she's coming back the way
that catherine hahn talks about it though she
says like the boilerplate thing i don't know
if agatha darkness is coming back you know
big wink from behind the camera everyone post
your memes she was one of the best things about
that show it's just like loki blowing up after
the first couple of movies that he was in like
oh we have to keep bringing this character back
he's just so fantastic but everybody let me know
in the comments talking about thunderbolts other
big future projects marvel villains coming back
when do you want them to bring agatha harkness
back but what will happen is is there been a
whole bunch of trailers that have dropped the past
couple of days so i'll try to get to all those
as fast as possible the justice league snyder cut
is dropping next week and then the day after that
falcon winter soldier episode 1 so my schedule
for falcon and winter soldier episodes will be
just like my schedule for my Wandavision videos
almost the exact same thing make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of those and leave all your requests for those
videos on the comments below if there's anything
that you want me to do for those everyone click
here for my brand new Wandavision post credit
scene video and click here for my Wandavision
finale video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!